you had a problem with your goat's
penis well I had my fainting goats your
what I had fainting goats I didn't know
that this was a thing but they're
actually bred to faint uhhuh what did
that have to do with a penis well one of
them died because his penis got clogged
up and I didn't know that goats there's
a there's a word for it I didn't know
that Gs are privy to a clogged penis
thing and you have to get the end cut
off but if you don't catch it in time it
can implode and I didn't know that so my
goat was in the corner all like sad and
usually when I shake the food it faints
and we laugh and it gets up and is an
actual thing fainting go it's not being
cruel yeah but I didn't know about the
penis thing and then he wasn't being
able to get saved because it had like
swollen up but I didn't know that
goats that that was a thing that
happened to them you know it's like you
know like Labradors get arthritis it's
like labradors get arthritis fainting
goats have exploding penises yeah but
the guild obviously didn't have a penis
so she survived oh and she's still alive
she's at my friend's
Ranch and they're the most beautiful
things yeah they would come in the house
I mean i' put a little nappy on them cuz
their poops are just like rabbit poops
it's not like big poops like my two
rottweilers their poops are like a mound
and their penises are okay yeah kep them
kept all intact and they're working dogs
they're my security
dogs so
that did I educate you all who knew that
I didn't know that and I said to the vet
why didn't you tell me that goats had a
penis problem and I would have kept my
eye out for it and checked well not
checked do you check you would you would
look at your goats well you just know
because it gets swollen and they get
sad they do that's not a laughing joke I
love I love my which is not like with
not like
humans know I think there are there are
some stuff that you you men get get
swollen and big there's very rarely s
like if you take Viagra doesn't it just
if you take Viagra it's kind of just it
swells and stays there but you don't get
sad stays there Rich doesn't it just
swell and stay
[Laughter]
there well of a certain age you have to
use Viagra so they say he say I've never
done have you have you have you been
with somebody who's used
Viagra I don't think so oh
her does she no women do it too women do
can women take Viagra women can take it
what happens what the vaginas explode
what happened no they don't it's not
like do they use it to squirt it's not
like no I think it just gets them more
excited I don't know I don't think women
use the
vi
[Music]
he